thank you
[Music]
all right guys welcome back to the
second best podcast on planet Earth
thank you very much for joining us today
on this happy Monday
um we're doing things a little bit
different today we've got a tremendous
guest in the building so I'm gonna stick
to what I've been doing the last few
weeks I'm gonna give a humble
introduction so don't open your mouth
until I finish the introduction please
sir okay as you can tell the sounds
different so you might not even see it
again James is sitting in a different
angles today so yeah yeah right so this
guy yeah this guy I hope he identifies
as a guy
has been is a real one he's a good one
to have first yeah
um because this prayer I remember
is one of the OG guys in the game facts
in the game that we play today as far as
you as far as UK podcasting is concerned
um this guy is one of the one of The
Originals uh has been going for years
and has set a precedent for what is
considered uh successful in uh UK
podcasting and he paved the way for a
lot of guys such as ourselves to to to
have a blueprint to work from and to see
what uh success looks likes looks likes
looks like and um as far as him as a
gentleman
um he's actually one of the first people
um to reach out and just be cool and be
nice to us and then the first time I met
him in person was very complimentary I
remember you spoke to him first yeah and
then I didn't said anything to him yeah
and he yeah he approached me came up to
me said hi wagwan uh I think it was uh
when was it I think it was Harry
Panera's birthday party and I was like
oh that's nice yeah yeah a very nice
acknowledgment
um and ever since then yeah you've made
loads of effort with us
um you've been super friendly to us and
uh welcoming to us and um yeah man
without any further Ado guys tazaar
black
[Laughter]
what's up
that was a nice intro man that was a
nice intro bro it's important so um yeah
I've been trying to do it for the last
few weeks I gave everyone an
introduction over the last few weeks and
it's important
um I think it's important to actually
make the effort to express how you truly
feel about someone
um and it actually makes you feel more
excited to spend time with that person
most people you just like experience on
a day to day yeah and then you focus on
the things that are just like their bad
habits or their usual qualities and
stuff like that and then if you were to
explain them to someone if someone asked
me to explain foohead to a crowd of
people it would make me feel way more
positive about food than I do on a daily
daily basis so yeah I'm gonna try and do
that for everyone that comes in the
studio
um and it's yeah I'm not lying as well
all that stuff is factual I love them I
love man thanks for having me bro thanks
for coming man thanks for being here you
were literally one of the first people
that said need to get on the show need
to get on the show so like finally happy
that we're we're here it's live in the
flesh yeah man I mean like you were like
what third choice fourth choice it's
fast
it's cool exercising yeah all right
warm-ups
um
um so yeah what we're gonna do before we
get into um the normal typical interview
style question style stuff we're gonna
have a little bit of fun yeah so we
asked the
um
oh listeners and viewers too yeah we
asked the hood
what how they feel about yeah so we've
got a bit of a roast we've got some
assumptions and some questions so cool
yes how it's gonna paint is I'm gonna do
the roast James is going to do the
assumptions and you're going to read out
your own questions and answer them yeah
all right cool cool okay it's all on the
iPad yeah so your questions are on the
iPad but don't read them yet I'm gonna
read The Rose first yeah he's gonna read
the assumptions about you obviously you
let us know if they're true or false uh
cool and then obviously you read out
your questions and you answer them yeah
yeah all good to go say less I'm glad
you got a thick skin man you're a good
guy yeah man yeah you better most yeah
yeah
Magic
race for taser
I'm sure taser has at least two black
toenails
swear
no maybe one maybe one
also for context right um you saw the
picture I put up with you on our
Instagram story or did you not no no it
was one of the what it was it was in the
studio your studio you're wearing I
think a brown like Snap trousers tea I
don't think you had a hat on so just for
context for context
bro's got them assistant coach snap
pants on assistant coach assistant coach
at any moment the wrestling ones yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah he
looks like the type of guy that asks for
more cheese on his Burger
I don't even know what that means what
does that mean bro it's funny to me bro
who's ever asked for more cheese on a
burger bro oh it's just funny to me
wrong
he looks like he writes the letter s
from the bottom up
hey
[Laughter]
It's the funniest thing I've read
oh [__]
and they got that from the picture yeah
this is all for one pick it was a good
pick as well it was a good pick I
thought I thought it would have been uh
it's cool it would have bangs
They probably cooked you once someone
said just who's taser I mean yeah
his outfits give him broke boy trying to
find an identity
sorry G how many of these we got we got
four more
yeah you're doing well you're doing well
you've got thick skin bro taser gets his
trim upside down
[Laughter]
yeah
upside down
what is that what's that a reverse face
that's the funniest thing I've heard
oh that was a good one thinks he has a
real deep voice but really he sounds
like Chris Tucker Oh dread now to be
fair your voice is deep yeah I don't
know but it gets higher when I'm very
passionate it does go up all right
self-aware I love that you're so dark
you don't own any bright ideas
okay
I've heard that from um what's his face
Michael Blackson yeah what is it yes one
of his ones oh say lessons
he's still in jokes he's still enjoying
that's roast over all right so I've got
some assumptions not gonna lie bro it's
not much better I'm not gonna lie bro
the assumptions aren't much better all
right let's go hit me
disburse said this man's definitely got
a lisp
it's it's obviously you don't but yeah
that's that's the Vibes that pick was
giving off picture fam
he looks like oh [__] say hell he looks
like the type of guy that deletes his
picks if they don't get enough likes you
know what
you're right I didn't work this hard to
be getting 20 likes
Instagram is broken it's broken
all right I haven't read these before
now right
looks like the type of man that tells a
girl he loves her after the second date
oh yeah that's very very wrong I swear
how many dates have you saved yeah I'm
not gonna lie bro how many dates yeah
one one I'm not saying I love you you
look like you love fat yeah you look
like you don't love love I'm the worst
opposite toxic not toxic but the Savage
no Shalom not sure
I don't get excited much okay okay
calm right he owns Black Sheets silk
ones too
I agree with that I agree with that yeah
laughs yes bro I was thinking I think
this one's facts
he can't go past Nando's without going
in for a quick feed
that's a racist remark a quick feed
swear
no all right he looks like he needs a
Bayesian girlfriend that's a chirps yeah
that's a church yeah that's a strong
Church thoughts on Asian women you like
beijings ax is a bit it's a bit tough
well I'll go on like it skyrockets a
little bit
all right last one taser looks like he
eats ass I don't know why I just get
that vibe
that's definitely a free shots listen up
where I swear I don't but we joke about
it
but I don't I don't think I I haven't no
what do you don't think not because I've
been down there and I'm having a bit too
low on the gooch area yeah
I might have I don't know consciously
nah unbeknownst to you it could have
been a you know I mean some people's a
bit close to our sums are forever apart
you know
they say less it's how God designed us
you know fair enough bro all right
you're up read your questions oh yeah
you got questions it should be
automatically on the just open all right
cool there we go
question one ask him how his GCSE maths
went when he was joint top class with
that Oxford girl
first of all she went Cambridge oh
um correction I think I got a B say be
in maths yeah Africans are good at math
isn't it I got Amos yeah I I did
terribly a mess they moved me to the set
where you weren't allowed to get a c and
I had to fight my way back up Foundation
yeah they put me in Foundation as a test
my mom came just gonna complain
everything oh wow they were like he
can't be in here they won't let you get
to see there's no point doing the class
oh you can't get a c you know Foundation
you can get c c is the highest basically
nah I must have been in the under that
one the remedial one
yeah our test didn't get get you a c oh
wow but lucky yeah I did get C in the
end but yeah yeah cool second question
would you date a Jamaican girl
yeah
oh I like the third question
what does it feel like being the sexiest
dark skin guy within the M25
M25 no
facts see ya I see you there
yeah yeah no I mean it's all right I
mean it weighs heavier on my shoulder
sometimes but
um we're here we're here I mean yeah
it was a long journey but we're here
gang why does it feel like Keith and
Marvel always picking on taser
because they are picking on data is it's
just I don't care I'm the friend that
doesn't care so whenever they want to
get their jokes off it's like okay cool
things have it okay plus apparently I do
a lot of outlandish stuff that they just
don't agree with so like what forever
checking me what's the one that they
cooked me for
um I had these um combats yeah that had
long um drawstrings okay yeah yeah and I
ordered them with loops
okay I didn't think it was anything bad
but they caught to me did you tie the
drawstring
what was it like to Denise or how long
yeah yeah to the knees yeah
it's in now though you see bear Brands
doing it now yeah I did it like bro
three years ago no but it was just for
the picture obviously I don't walk out
with it and the jewels and just swing it
beside me um
Essentials ones are long bro I want to
wrap it around my waist
vexes me they cooked me I think they
said I looked like the um you know the
characters from the movie us with the
the scissors yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah
and then it's just been like okay and
then also another thing
when I first started going gym I used to
just literally eat tinned mackerel and
rice yeah struggle food that's a rem
Ting I don't know why your face is like
that don't do that to me you said you
get your money now exactly our yard used
to stink do you remember every morning
this guy will cook up the microwave it's
so easy though it's like two pound three
pound meal and it's quick on the goal so
I used to bang that out when I didn't
have pee then I moved to East and then I
took a few tins as I moved in never
touched them again and all of a sudden
it's been the consistent narrative I'm
like you man I've upgraded that common
man yeah so that's one of them
next question what's your favorite thing
to do in your spare time
I'll say Gold Gym
watch documentaries
and
and listen to music what um documentary
is watching at the moment
you know it's very random yeah I just
think about something that's happening
in life and then just YouTube it so
um last week I was watching
Paris Hilton like uncovered like okay
the actual person that she is okay
following around in her yard because
she's not who people think she is yeah
I've heard she's actually Bear smart you
know yeah I'm saying so I heard she went
into one did you hear about the school
that she went to when she was younger
because her family come from money in it
yeah I knew that they sent her off to
some crazy school bro when she was a kid
and the school got shut down for
something uh where they literally like
it's for misbehaving kids okay and they
literally steal you in the night they
literally take you in your pajamas put
you in the back of a van and then move
you to this and they're like they're
tactics for like discipline and stuff
like that were like solitary and stuff
it's given handmade still bro it's mad
it's mad she's been through a lot to the
point where she doesn't even know who
she is oh she just plays so many
different currency prices some yeah
along those lines but she's very smart
very business savvy her sister claims to
be the only person that really knows who
she is and she and then there was a
random fact in a documentary that I
watched she's never worn the same outfit
twice
it doesn't surprise me wow that every
single picture is a different um her
wardrobe is probably the size of this
building it's like it's mad that's
insane it's got bread her bread is long
yeah that was what I found interesting
and then recently uh I wanted to know
what happened between India and Pakistan
and Pakistan it's a good shout it's
funny because the interesting thing was
because basically how the conversation
started was I have a friend and she was
like I'm from
I'd guess a number of places okay but
then she stalked me and was like don't
say Pakistan okay I'm not Pakistan I'm
Indian okay why do you have a beef
clearly everyone knows why they had the
beef but
they have a beef sorry I don't I have no
idea why it's something to do with like
religion politics it's a long story but
what I was trying to get her to
understand that the confusion between
Indian and Pakistani girls is a lot of
you are displaced but your location
didn't change like for example what's
going on right now in Russia because
they believe Ukraine is their land yeah
so I am I wrong for assuming that a girl
who's from Ukraine looks Russian yeah I
hear you I hear you because nothing you
didn't move you they just claimed this
land yeah yeah but before like 10 years
ago this was Russia yeah now it's
Ukraine yeah people didn't change yeah
so you might look Russian but you're
you're from Ukraine so it was that kind
of conversation but I just randomly just
go on YouTube and search that okay and
just and then just get knowledge on one
20 30 minutes I don't like documentary
that over an hour yes 30 25 minutes I'm
in June just random stuff
I like that very inquisitive all right
um You can only save one of us James or
fuhad oh
fossil fear
I didn't ask the question I just wrote
it down bro
I'm going to see a few guys because he's
dark skin
fine that's the only distinction
I'll take it whatever
I don't need saving that's my answer
[Laughter]
um second to last question highlights
and low lights of 2022
I mean highlights would be the r b and
slow jam experience I mean Chucky
everyone will go deep into that yeah
yeah so I think that's a short answer
um low
um
I don't know man
okay when I um when a cyclist crashed
into my car
a cyclist yeah I saw a guy in a moped
okay
um Uber drive it was a delivery driver
I didn't speak English oh for God's sake
and but found in English to basically
let me know that this is not my bike
this is not my shift and I'm not
supposed to be in this country so I'm
not in short oh raw fuming because the
good man I am I helped him up
I let him go
and I thought I didn't get his details I
couldn't I was so angry and you know
pissed me off as I'm helping him up here
a car's driven by this is in stream a
car driven bike went on the window down
your teeth you're good I'm like oh I'm
not allow it it's two in the morning
swear I've got back into my car above my
wing mirror is gone
and I've got the same car the Winger is
not cheap yeah it cost me about it cost
me four figures to fix
yeah they're serious but four figures
bro because I had to get though we had
to get the wing mirror to get the door
panel yeah and then the back door the
part of the door is connected to the
front so it's the whole oh yes brother
reach four figures to fix
wow and I was just going on holiday
Cancun so I dropped the car off before I
went to Cancun with demand him and then
when I got back from Cancun my car was
fixed it was just such a cash flow off
that was unnecessary but I'm alive
last question what is your body count
is very much broken we're moving on to a
park called the origin story now so this
is where you just tell us how taser
black was formed so talk to where what
was the birth of taser black
yeah let's start actually let me give
you like a pinpoint to actually start
from
um
where actually I'm gonna go way back
okay because I actually know [__] all
about you as a part away from what I see
every day
um so three shots people are going to be
bored as [__] but calm there's like four
of them
[Laughter]
so where did you where did you grow up
in London yeah North West London okay
um an estate called Mitchell Brook
and then at 16 I moved to an estate
called set reps
stayed in North as well yesterday from
each other okay you have siblings
for a sister and three brothers I'm the
eldest you're the eldest this is me my
sister and then my brothers okay okay
gang all right calm so born here as well
yeah where are you from Nigeria born
part Royal High School Northwest Central
Middlesex all right okay so like
from what we see from you
is like very and this is actually quite
different to I'd say most people
identify these days as like
um entrepreneurs but I would say don't
get gas you're actually one of the only
people who I actually think moves that
way yeah yeah without saying it I've
never heard you say that word yeah but
you move your your movements move like
it because I was actually having a
conversation about you to someone a few
weeks ago and I was like this brother
does too much I don't understand why
he's working so hard always business guy
makes money just sleep yeah well I sleep
I actually do sleep but uh so where was
like where do you can you identify a
Time whether growing up or in adulthood
that you had this urge to be a little
bit more entrepreneurial to be
interested in business
um yeah
um
I think where can I stop maybe my dad my
dad was like a import export okay so but
I always used to see my dad buying and
selling something either he's buying it
in bulk from here or buying it from Asia
yeah yeah like one time do you remember
33 tens
so when they first hit the market my dad
walked into my house with like two
thousand of them Jesus
I had a different phone like every other
week because he would just bring out the
next phone this is the 3210 in that box
is the Face-Off with the antenna then I
had the 8250 the Banana Phone The Matrix
light but that had every single one of
their knockers wow just coming through
the house mad so but obviously the aim
was to buy and sell buy and sell yeah
yeah yeah so I think I kind of adopted
it there where it's just like no this
this guy's good I didn't I didn't ever
see the money by the way I realized you
you just saw I just saw stuff yeah
come and go yeah yeah so then um at 16
my dad has paid for all of us to go to
Nigeria for summer holiday and then he
took us to like the village where he
grew up then a couple roads down he
showed us what he's been
essentially spending his money on some
fat mansion that he's been building for
like the past 10 years okay so I was
like raw and he was basically like yeah
so this is where we were planning on
moving
I was like what what he wants to meet
the whole family there yeah
[Laughter]
so I think from then but this is
obviously hindsight I'm looking thinking
back here I think from then I'm just
like no I've got to kind of get it on my
own so I think 18 I asked my dad for
some money because I wanted to start
something okay and he said no and I've
never asked my dad for money since then
18 was the last time I asked for that
for money wow I've never asked me for
money since and uh when did you so when
did you move out
so but it's it's a longer story so my
dad got himself into a bit of trouble
I've discussed this on the Pod so he
left my house around I think 21 22.
so technically I was the head of the
house yeah yeah it was weighing heavy on
my shoulders but I never really
showed it to anyone so I looked it as my
mom lived with me I took on the
responsibility of the bills looking
after my siblings
um it was it wasn't even I wouldn't say
it was hard it's just I just did it yeah
I just did it before you knew it I was
23 finished uni looking for a job
then started being faded straight off
the uni yeah yeah it's gonna be 11 years
this month
I thought it was not new but like not
that old no 11 years yeah same business
partner as well me and Matthew how did
that start yeah we used to go to another
night called yo-yos in Notting Hill okay
yeah yeah and sick Vibe and there was
one time they did like an Adidas party
and they invited like I wouldn't call
them influences but that's at the time
yeah I don't know what you'd call them
but just people who were popular yeah
yeah
so the venue held about 20 220 people I
probably said hi to about 180. and I saw
it as I can do one of mine this is this
is like I know everyone in there yeah
and he said the same thing as well he
said hello to about 108 years was just
like but you know everyone like let's do
our own nights so I started by doing a
house party in my house the current
house that my mom's living in and
it banked I think it was my 21st or
maybe 22nd that I I paid some girl that
lived in Wilson High Road 80 pounds to
use her yard for the Saturday night as I
said use this to go out Raven let me
just use your flat because she was
moving out anyway so okay yeah yeah yeah
yeah and we had about
charged a pound on the door okay
at the end of the night I had 326 pounds
in that key
there was no way 326 people came to this
party but I'm like no you man I'm gonna
take this event thing seriously so then
obviously just shopping around
um decided on a pub in East called I
don't think he's even there anymore I
used to call River Factory on in White
Chapel hide it for my birthday I think
this is my 20
third birthday yeah because my birthday
is the first faded yeah yeah yeah yeah
2012. okay and 350 people rammed it out
and it was around that time remember you
couldn't really hear Jay-Z Meek Mill
French Montana all of that in the clubs
but we were playing that okay because it
was like yeah we listened to my uh
that's what I want to party too and
everyone just bought into it and
literally that year was probably a great
year for us bear in mind the year we
started we weren't allowed to sell
tickets online there was no there was no
infrastructure
or relying on you like saying you're
coming and the pain on the door so
that's how I started but I missed the
window of going to other people's ways
and flying outside I missed that window
I I I kind of started around the window
of WhatsApp broadcasts okay and
um
Facebook yeah yeah yeah so that's the
kind of window I started in okay and
then um yeah I just kept doing it kept
doing it and then
in regards to the event space just kept
adapting okay so okay cool this is this
is the party lane let's do something for
the comedians people are like comedies
started doing live comedy shows then
we've done that uh you know that I don't
know if you have realized there's this
new it's not even new but I wouldn't say
we started it as well because shout out
Ori actually because Ori actually did it
um the first night that I remember where
you go to a bar and you play games
he was the first one that I know that
did it um Connect Four cards yeah yeah
yeah Super Nintendo yeah okay so we took
that formula and then started it in
shortage okay the venue that's called
bully bullets and now it used to be
called Far Rockaway okay we took over
that venue used to fill it out literally
every Sunday about seven to eight
hundred people throughout the whole
summer people to go box park off the Box
part they come in there mad killed that
summer
unfortunately the owner of that venue
wasn't paying his rent um so he lost the
venue we got kicked out had to move to
dalston and it just didn't continue yeah
yeah yeah
um funny story with faded there was a
part where we were banned from like
Hackney every venue was just saying no
to us okay so we actually did a campaign
where this is fairly coming to an end in
the UK okay done the last event in uh a
venue called
um connect in Victoria it's near Pasha
and that summer we started doing
International Date so that's what we
started doing Amsterdam started doing
Barcelona and then we did Croatia
but then
the funny thing about venues is every
bar manager just moves around okay so
they just go from one venue to the other
yeah yeah because they were in the
industry they will know each other yeah
technically so when he gets another
venue they'll give us a phone call hey
guys come check out my venue see if you
look and do a night and me and Matthew
thinking ain't we banned in this area
yeah yeah yeah so
um the Curtin Hotel took a punt with us
and allowed us to do nights there but
then told us we couldn't call it faded
so that's what we gave birth to refresh
so refresh became faded sister okay so
faded is where you can come and dress
like this yeah yeah refresh you dress up
a bit more but you listen to r b yeah
yeah yeah so then we had faded a refresh
running side by side but then as we we
got older so now we're 27 28. I realized
I prefer to party at refresh as opposed
to faded so refresh is where I get more
excited okay because faded it's just
it's just doing his thing yeah yeah yeah
yeah then refresh had a year where we
moved into the Curtin hotel and we had
like a
um a business model that just worked
guest list only kind of thing okay oh my
God
anybody who went refresh here will tell
you that's why we wanted their best
nights really swear but we've had Crypt
come through Conan stormzy Maya Jamar
Cadet rest in peace like so many people
came through this building to pump a
party in this hotel at the time it was
so sick and then the reason why we
stopped was kind of around lockdown yeah
yeah everything just messed up
Jesus bro busy guy so that's banging so
when you're when this is all built in so
when's faded's building this started off
and you're doing obviously let's call it
from your 23rd birthday yeah
what were you doing
other sorts of income wise were you
working a normal job
it's a funny story I used to work for a
company called Provident yeah and I was
a debt collector
okay okay so the idea the reason why I
started that job is
um so like I said I was the head of the
house so I had to do the school run yeah
I take my little brother to school okay
I don't have a job my mom's telling me
to wake up 7 30 to get ready to take my
brother to school yeah I need to come
back to bed like I didn't understand but
I was always up early and then one day I
bumped into one of my old friends she
has a child that goes to that school but
she does the school run goes to work and
makes it back in time to pick up her
door so I'm like what do you do yeah
yeah she's like tease off I tell you you
don't believe you won't believe you yeah
I said tell me it tells me so how much
you're making she was on about eight
bills a week
she's done she finishes her shift she
does her starts to shift at like 10
finishes by two I'm like what he builds
a week three two a month
it gets worse she does one day a week
nah nah nah nah this is what I'm saying
yeah she does one day a week because
she's patting her ting to the point
where she goes around and does her
rounds once a week I'll say yes so when
I started I've started fresh yeah I'm
thinking I'm gonna be on her level
I've had to so I'm like all right cool
first of all let me get a drink I know
what kind of job I'm doing yeah I don't
want one that's local to my area yeah
yeah yeah because I don't want to go to
someone's house and their mom is telling
me that I don't have the 10 pounds today
can you come back tomorrow next week and
I'm like I know your son he blew a
hundred pound of faded I don't want that
so let me just go to an area that's
non-existent to me so I picked the area
in West London they gave me that book
and then I had to go through the book
can start processing meeting my clients
I start building a relationship so I'm
going to their houses and I'm like I can
see that you've taken out a grand loan
you currently still owe 500 pound how
are you going to work it they're like
well I normally pay five pound a week I
said five pound a week you feel like I'm
gonna be coming to your house
but that's the kind of like really yeah
yeah yeah yeah the one the um the person
before me yeah was doing yeah so I'm
going around getting around going around
and it's all adding up now and I'm like
all right cool so I was on about three
bills a week okay building building
building and then I had one client who
was giving me 600 pounds I think the
idea was whatever you collect you take
ten percent okay
make this a premium you know that when
you go to the Payday Loans on on the
high road it's a premium they give you a
grand they probably expect you to pay
back two and a half but it's across like
a year yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah I was
doing that doing that doing that and I
think I went to one woman's house and
she always invited me in for coffee
oh I'm just like ma'am can you just give
me the free Palm please yeah I don't
need to comment please come in let me
make you a couple tell me about your day
I'm like I ain't got but I had to be
nice yeah yeah I couldn't keep doing
that like it was it was draining for me
you have to you have to kind of be a
piece of [__] excuse my French to work
that kind of job yeah so then but for
some reason my friends they were happy
as in the woman the girl that got me the
job her clients were happy go lucky like
I understand this is how I have to get
the money yeah yeah they're welcoming
when she comes over she's either she's
out with me I have to build mine
relationship after three months I was
like I can't do this no more man so I
went back to work where you kind of drop
off the the bag and the manager was a
piece of [__] anyway I punch him off I
see him you know
slimy guys man it was one of the Demons
I just said I don't want this job no
more you're not gonna get a job
elsewhere
really really
them kind of guy so um I left that but I
did that temporarily because
um I had a Vauxhall Astra as my second
car but my as in the second car I drove
on my first car for an idiot like an
idiot I got a 1.8 swear to the petrol
was kid yeah imagine so I I used to
drive it to feed it Park way around the
corner and it walked away but then after
a while I was like
now I've got a car let me use it but
after petrol's killing me I didn't have
a job now failure wasn't really because
there's some months we have faded I made
three bills just lasted me the whole
month and there's some failures where
I'll make a grant yeah so I was
literally just literally checked by
check by check some pages would do two
faded so I'm expecting a grand twice and
unfortunately you didn't go the way we
planned so I've only took eight bills or
something it was kind of like going like
that until we just kept going on there
yeah here we are today I was sick so
when did um so taught me timeline so
we're doing
faded from 2013 from 20 yeah 2012 2013
moving on
um when did
your second so three shots yeah so three
shots started 2016 2016 April 2016. is
this your second business venture
business business venture
um
outside of events yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah how did that start so
um Marvin Keith had a radio show on on
top FM and they had the timeline in a
troll code okay anybody who knows about
on top will tell you Marv Keith and
there was another guy Rob had the
timeline on the choke hold every Sunday
okay I never looked into this show but
okay I don't know why because I was out
on a Sunday but if you were at home you
would tune into this show so many people
know about this show but anyway that's
how they kind of like done their thing
and built their following and I guess
had one foot in so that's like this
media space here so but and I started
talking to them Rob had a thing called
the Dirty games men play and then he
used to do a live event where women and
men would debate and I was like I want
to get involved in that I like these
kind of conversations and cool it's like
a guy into these events but I couldn't
bring a crowd my crowd just didn't seem
so it didn't cross over yeah with him
and I'll be honest and say that I
actually went in there said let me do my
thing let me start up but I'll build to
the point where we join our crowds my
crowd just didn't come for some reason
she's like taser you gotta let go today
I said no problem then Keith was like yo
I see you want to do that thing have you
heard of podcasting what's that I want
to do YouTube he said no no check out
podcasting my sister's kind of spoken to
me about podcasting it looks like
something that we can actually get into
plus Chucky does it I'm like oh yeah
yeah oh yeah Chucky's got um half course
all right cool cool Chucky I said Chucky
let me come to one of your episodes and
see how it works went on there brother
it was so easy I said huh this is what
you'll do I'm getting involved man got
this and then the engineer at the time
was Savage then but remember back then
he was um he didn't have an identity
yeah it was just a voice yeah yeah
because remember when we started
podcasting there was no visuals who's
this guy's voice he's on filthy just
hear his voice he's on our podcast he
featured on a couple other podcasts you
just hear his voice but he was the
engineer that's why he was always there
I'm saying so then um
and I knew I've known Dan since like I
was 14. oh yeah he's from West London
yeah my school kind of borders West
London so that's how I know a lot of men
from West so I've known that I'm like oh
cool we're gonna use your studio he's
like yeah no problem just chat when
you're ready started committing to using
Dan's every two weeks when we started
three shots every two weeks about it
literally picked up the moment we
dropped the first episode
there was no building we just literally
said all right cool we're gonna try this
new thing pick the date drop the link on
that date 7000 first day this sound must
be nice it must have been great yeah
it was just but we didn't we didn't know
who to compare it to we did yeah yeah
yeah people are telling us we're buying
and listens I don't know what metric to
measure I just load up the seven
thousand here amazing that is what it is
people are just hating on us hating on
us but because of the hate more people
want to know your facts bro 100 that's
what always happens I think we hit 50
000 after like two months oh your mama
honestly honestly probably I'm telling
you it was just moving mad yeah when we
hit a mill
I was like there's no way a million
people has listened to man there's no
way but we started going out more okay
just bumping into people yeah I heard
this I heard that like even just now
downstairs someone delivered past me and
goes there that thing you did in
McDonald's is a mad thing
yeah yeah yeah like people listen but
you don't they're not gonna come up to
you and tell you of course but for us in
the beginning it was like that so I was
like you know what this is sick so then
I think after about a year it was no
sorry the beginning of that year we've
done the decided to do a live show
the end of that year so that was like
November or December announced the first
date tickets sold out we did a venue
called sync in shortage at the time 200
tickets sold out in a day yeah I said
let's announce another date sold out so
that's another day sold out so we did
three dates every other week yeah yeah
the format was like wait what what is
the format of a live show I said let's
just get on this front and just talk and
it worked people loved it so then we
went into the next year like confident
art called this pod thing makes sense
let's keep going question so it's got
you off would you say that was the first
like live podcast the thing you went to
yeah your first show was your first live
podcast thing you went yeah mad first
time I even had heard of anybody podcast
wise talk about doing a show yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah before it was like meet
and greets yeah yeah yeah on audience
with but it wasn't live show yeah
because I wouldn't even know what
blueprint to go off but I was watching
Joe Budden religiously Give Me A Sign
like yeah yeah nothing on their end so I
was like then there's no other podcasts
like tax Stone was doing effing the Reed
but there was no one that was giving me
like an event and I come from an event's
background yeah yeah I'm like bro like I
mean you look must know the first
six seven months of podding
there's no bread coming yes
yeah yeah we were stuck for a minute
just do events to try to make a little
bit of bread like recook this studio
petrol money like people think it's a
joke but committing to doing a pod
at the time obviously now I think some
people can actually just start off with
a brand partnership
really paid them and so it's not the
same as yeah yeah go into the studio
with no money being generated and just
recording and giving you content and
remember we're giving out three hours
content you know yeah yeah you man talk
to me first I'm saying when we started
seeing all these new podcasts coming out
oh yeah here's our new episode I'm
seeing 30 minutes I'm like hey we ain't
even done our intro I mean yeah but um
because it's so second nature to us we
don't actually mind so then when things
started even getting more like they
became more of an infrastructure we're
seeing the prices of what people are
asking for for 20 minutes I'm like but
I'll give you three hours for
for times
nine yeah yeah essentially is that is
that the metric yeah remember even Joe
Budden went through that problem as well
he's like you like paying x amount for
albums
but I'm essentially giving you an album
every week yeah yeah kind of thing how's
the metric not the same yeah right guys
we're just going to take a very quick
break to pay some bills right so listen
up Spring has finally sprung and our
friends at manscape the leaders in below
the way screaming screaming below the
waist freaking grooming have the best
tools for some spring cleaning in your
USD pants trust me your confidence will
be blooming like the flowers look your
best this spring and join the other 8
million men guys it was seven last month
it's eight your boys are doing
consistent reason it's gone from seven
to eight when we started I'm pretty sure
it was like two two yeah because we were
saying two million men four million
balls I remember yeah bro and that was
eight million men 16 million balls give
or take
joining the other eight million men who
can trust manscape and all you need to
do is go to massgate.com use the code
sng Sierra November and they're gonna
get 20 off and free shipping worldwide
right let's get back to the episode oh
yeah that's the conversation for another
day anyway but mad so that's our free
shots kind of took off and then so you
tase up not saying sorry Keith and Marv
knew each other separately before you
yeah okay all right okay okay cool man
so now we've got faded faded on on the
books three shots on the books what was
the next venture was it the old school
or was it 40s old school is last year so
it would have been I was only a year old
yeah we did like two in during lockdown
the pandemic okay nothing to discuss but
that's what kind of let us know that
this is gonna work okay yeah and then we
just started hitting the ground running
what was the first one I think it was
I get the dates mixed up there was one
that we done October okay 2021 yeah
during lockdown yeah
that had about 200 people by eight bangs
because it was like the idea of just
hearing r b slow jams all night yeah
yeah
I'm saying if everyone was like
didn't know what to expect but then when
you got there and you're just singing
and drunk and Vibes and it's like no
this can work it's a karaoke Vibe just
yeah yeah yeah so then we did Amazing
Grace okay there's a venue in uh London
Bridge
the venue's beautiful but if you pack it
out it is hot yeah yeah so the first one
we did there went well did another one
in there went well when we started
seeing more guys Amanda was like
clocking that right it is babes there
yeah yeah so we said we've outgrown this
venue so then we went to site five okay
that's the if you see the footage
um it's like a colorful venue in
um East outdoor space that was the one
that everyone said no these went on to
something okay we we did I think 800
people day party gang and that's the one
that was like alright cool let's take
this thing seriously okay so the end of
the year with Halloween yeah we brought
out Donell Jones oh yeah I remember that
one yeah yeah that was the one that we
couldn't make it to yeah yeah
and then ended the year with
um alternate
and then obviously this year is just
like we announced from the beginning of
the year we're gonna try and hit 10 C's
this year so far we've done Brum money
and then we've got leads coming up yeah
yeah yeah sick you're killing it and
you're trying you're selling out quick
yeah they're doing well so that's why
I've you've not been there so yeah we've
been twice
yeah that was effective we didn't go to
the Manchester one the other day yeah
bro you man and kill it so yeah so like
at this point so then you've got how did
40 start so 40 started back in the day
2009 um again 2000 and what yeah 2009
nine family you said nine my brain said
19. nine yeah yes talk to us I was like
I was at Uni when I started 40s um I
started 40s the same year although same
year or year after Benjo me and Benjo
grew up on the same estate okay yeah so
Benjo was my like oh let me know
big bro I'm gonna say Mentor yeah
he wrote it so but we come from the same
mistake the same mud basically we've
seen the same things basically and I
remember he was um doing banjo out of
his um Polo and then he's gonna he's
gonna laugh when I say this here but
basically we found out something
together okay and then we basically
exploited it together okay and it
allowed us to kind of give birth to Our
Brands okay but I lost the motivation so
I stopped 40s whereas he continued yeah
yeah but I went into events yeah so I
had 40s there sold a bunch of hoodies
some people still have the hoodies still
now yeah the quality that I went for
back then was crazy yeah um that's why
I'm I take pride in the quality now yeah
for sure I love that so um so I had that
then before T stands for True Talent
takes time and it's also the names of me
and my siblings so I'm Tobar my sister's
Timmy my brother's Toby and Tammy
forties love that and then obviously the
new edition My Little Nick's little
brother is Timmy and hopefully he can
have his company called five T's because
my dad's company was called three T's oh
six
yeah because there's only three of us
and when he had another son I thought
you know let me do 40s yeah yeah so
that's how that came about oh man
um and then this year obviously last
year was going well and I said you know
what let me bring something back because
I kind of want to diversify my portfolio
yeah yeah I'm doing events I'm doing
podcasting I'm doing content creation
let me sell much yeah that's what I
thought let me bring 40s back and that's
how I kind of revamped it so the first
logo that the one that you always wear
yeah is the logo from 2009. before let
me hit them with that and then I'm
getting fresh again with this okay so
how long did it take for the for the
rebranding of this one because obviously
you dropped this not too long ago yeah
yeah so I didn't want to leave that logo
okay but I started looking at it and
thinking would someone pick this up to
go Raven
you can't explain what it says and I
know we don't know like Gucci or
Balenciaga all of them Brands there and
we wear it pride but for some reason
when it comes to UK Brands there's a bit
of a I've got to know the person yeah
yeah so I thought you know let me make
it a bit more presentable and then maybe
people start wearing it so that's how I
kind of change the logo for they make it
more modern a lot of um Brands nowadays
are going for this like straight from
the neck down to the Rim Yeah Yeah type
design let me do that but that one did
well it's doing well it's still selling
people like the quality yeah the quality
is buff thank you thank you so um that's
why I brought that back but I'm not
trying to do it as if I'm trying to
build a brand for now I'm just a guy
with an idea and I sell it so I'm
probably gonna drop like three or four
capsules a year yeah yeah until it gets
to the point where it's like all right
cool let's turn into a brand whereas
you've got other brands that will do
like a new capsule every month I'm not
doing that mine it's just literally
three four designs every year okay if
you like it come [__] with me if not
then all right cool so where this is a
complete throwback where did that name
taser come from
um school year eight year nine there was
a
an MC battle apparently it's gonna take
place in the playground
year nine I've still got in my mom's
house I was looking at them the other
day bear people if I used to write bars
y'all got a better piece of paper drop a
quick four on the spot quick four quick
four quick four how about if you don't
know taser ask about taser did that
we're making AKA taser dark skin taser
log on to taser I'm interactive just
type in taser the girls don't call me my
lattes are slang do that from taser
shook him out in the lower back with a
taser if you want to catch taser just
dial taser come on
[Laughter]
yeah if you're interested just come to
the playground do the jumping I'm like
but I ain't got a name um the first
thing that came to mind was the bionics
I said bionics why but I don't know but
I honestly couldn't tell you but then
someone told me yo big um nasty crew
their DJ is called Bionics
but then there's a guy called laser from
my estate so um if you listen to North
Weezy the guy at the end okay um it's
it's a laser from the Northeast and we
got things a lot with no door keys he's
from our state as well okay so I said
you know what he's my favorite MC right
now laser
and the black was literally literally
on MySpace I was taser Dan
okay when everyone transitioned to
Facebook yeah Dan wasn't long enough for
a surname on Facebook all right so
they're like three letters is not enough
okay so I'm gonna use my last name I was
like
black my favorite color okay
until you said your name like 20 minutes
ago I know you was taser do you know
what I mean and I feel like majority of
people know you as taser as opposed to
like your obviously we say our names on
the Pod like we don't have aliases like
that but yeah that's that's fine but you
know that it's funny that you say that
yeah because I'm not actually people
think that it's because I'm embarrassed
about my name okay okay but people don't
understand it's not like my mom my nan
my dad my daughter everyone calls me
taser yeah so look when you when you
hear taser look at it as it's my first
name yeah yeah not a slang or nickname
yeah October like tobra candy is my name
full name oluwatoba akande I'm not shy
to say it but people just assume that
why you give me your road name I'm like
oh babes someone giving you my real name
I'll give you my name baby everyone my
name
it's actually like my first name but um
that's how taser was born sick man
that's a that's the origin story was
possible yeah you've got to play
different Avenues boy what's like what
are your thoughts moving forward in
terms of like business side because
you're doing like obviously so we've got
events we've got podcasting you're doing
one extra stuff do merch merch content
creation yeah yeah yeah like yeah yeah
you're branching out content-wise as
well which I liked yeah yeah tick tocks
pop in thank you thank you thank you
yeah that's hard work Hey listen it's
not it's not easy man but um I shoot
content all the time and and anywhere
you see me any I'm always very big on
can I be myself yeah yeah I'm not trying
to act and be someone else just because
I have a following yeah yeah the reason
why I have a following is because I've
been myself yes as long as whoever I
work with understands that and allows me
to be me cool let's go so then was
working with just hype for about a year
and they would allow me to be me with
the taser black helpline and the content
from that was actually it was actually
when you get people's dilemmas yeah oh
but I've been doing that from like my
space days just throwing out a question
or even on BBM throwing out a question
on my status and then yeah engage I've
always been that kind of person just
engaged and get feedback okay well what
would you do if this happened what would
you do if that happened what if I just
love engaging with people which kind of
leads to events I like being around
people or bringing people together just
to have a good time so as long as that's
the main um
the belly of whatever I'm doing I'm
happy to do it so moving forward
it's creating content and having good
times with my friends man yeah that's
literally how do you split sorry to cut
you off bro how do you split your time
because obviously mentally it must be
tasking and thinking about like okay
I've got these amount of teas or hoodies
I need to sell today or need to ship out
today I've got an event drop in tomorrow
or I've got a podcast I need to do on
Wednesday like how do you manage all of
this okay on a week by week basis or day
by day basis so I have a base basic
schedule yeah okay
Tuesday I record three shots yeah 9 p.m
till whatever time in the morning okay
I'm with Marvin Keith yeah
Friday or Saturday is faded okay and
then
if I'm not going to that faded event
wherever then Friday Saturday Sunday is
my family okay yeah daytime yeah I mean
my daughter with my mom or whatever and
then after about nine they go to bed and
then I come out and I'm out to play okay
that's how I look at it that's the basic
okay
if I get invited to events it has to
fall on a Tuesday Wednesday or Friday
maybe a Monday if not I can't come okay
as I look at it yeah yeah if it's
something that I have to move I remember
I now have to contact Keith and moth to
say yo that Tuesday I can't come
and then I need to find out what other
part of the week they're available yeah
that I need to find out if the state the
studios available
Saturday or Sunday I gotta make sure I
got Child Care yeah so for me Tuesday so
any all of these that's why all these
award shows and screenings and Cinema
you can't see me there if it's on a
Tuesday there's too much stress I've got
to do so much things around and then I'm
a single guy I like to be around women
so they've got to kind of adjust around
there as well so a girl can call me
Wednesday 2 A.M I'll be free yeah yeah
I'll be free yeah yeah because I got a
Saturday
Society yeah so sometimes it's hard
because you got there's some girls I
would love to meet but they do what nine
to five I'm like where am I going to
meet you yeah if it's not after work
your work yeah because I'm not skipping
my way yeah yeah yeah I'm not listening
to the Saturday or Sunday yeah to come
and see you so if you're not full on a
Wednesday night but Wednesday night
sometimes these Champions League
yeah babes I'll come check it yeah but
after 10 30. 10 30 why can't you come
early are you watching Champions League
like it's rough man so that's my basic
Tuesday
um
podcasting Saturday Sunday sometimes
Friday
um events and then around it everything
just kind of fits in
Tony said that I sell full teasers if
I'm a drug dealer
that is it's true because I thought I
have a campaign I can't have a plan it's
just
to be fair your stories are moving bad
drug dealers yeah
yeah then there's always like
a yeah let me let me get that one I'm
like all right cool go on that's sold
two more you um you posted one in your
story and I was like bro I like that one
I holded you straight away I'll give me
that one you're like boom yeah that's
how I'm flogging it but it's like it's
easy for me to do it that way because
right now if someone came in and said I
can give you a structure I was looking
at them like now you're just trying to
eat off me yeah yeah working how it's
working now but I do know I need to
become a bit more professional with it I
get it I'm very aware but right now it's
working if it's working right now bro
it's working and you don't there is no
middleman you just me gang you're doing
it doesn't it bro all right I got one
last bit we're gonna move on to a
dilemma in a minute I've got one last
question because this is obviously
broadcasting is the bag broadcasting has
changed
um and you guys have been doing it for a
minute
first question
so a lot of potentially I think we've
actually surprisingly got very different
audiences so for those who don't know
obviously you guys started in 2016
before that there was really not really
anything going on
um in this country anyway and you guys
uh started something that obviously went
big quick what was it like for you so
obviously you explained the first day
banged first few months bind live shows
started to bang
what was it like for you or what
difference did it make to you guys when
Spotify signs you
oh the money I mean the content didn't
change yeah we were very adamant that
the content didn't change but to be fair
as you get older your content changes
yeah of course yeah because um I
remember when we used to record in um
radar and someone commentating
which takes a scene someone because the
last three weeks of his content he's not
he hasn't been as
as typical as he would have been yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah but women I
boisterous on that but I was actually I
actually was seeing something I'm like
you got that attentive that's mad so I
started becoming more conscious about
how I'm speaking on the Pod and stuff
like that because you don't know who's
listening I'm very conscious about
dropping I'd never really hardly ever
drop names yeah if I do the person knows
I'm talking about them any stories I've
shared about women I've never said a
name yeah yeah yeah yeah Alias I've
never said a name so sometimes I even
meet the person who's listened to the
episode and they didn't even know I was
talking about them yeah yeah facts so
I'm very conscious about that but just
as as we've grown there's been moments
where they've tried to cancel us
for things I didn't know was offensive I
mean but then you learn once it hits the
timeline yeah yeah yeah yeah the
timeline oh so so this is offensive now
I'm not going to talk about that again
um so you just learn and grow and I just
hope that our listeners just offer us
that Grace that we're just human as well
we don't know
what is in and what's not we're all
learning as well so it took us a while
and I've seen podcasts come go through
that situation where they're about to
get canceled they literally don't make
it out the other side whereas we've gone
through that cycle so many times Brands
don't want to work with you then they
Hollow you six months later your numbers
are still up you want to work I just
kind of know the game now so it's just
like all right cool whatever so Spotify
came along
um it's only after
about
two years in that we realized the only
reason why Spotify actually accommodated
us is because we were at BBC for six
weeks so they saw it as right BBC can
work with you yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah professionalism okay so that was
kind of like entry point and then when
we got into
um Spotify big up Austin actually he's
at um I think he's at Atlantic now
but he's the one that kind of
facilitated that movie yeah and then um
yeah we were Spotify for however many
long and then yeah we're not with them
anymore they decided to go down a
different route um cut ties with them
but yeah it was a good experience though
nice little journey and yeah they they
looked after us man you're one of the
first now yeah yeah you were they gave
the one of the when you say one of the
first I said as in our space yeah
obviously they had like the Amy schumers
and yeah yeah but yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah we managed
to negotiate the first one yeah it was
actually
it's an interesting conversation because
I didn't know what to expect I can
imagine for sure that's buff bro yeah
I'm gassed yeah you guys really did the
damn thing boy tried man we tried man
and obviously I the plan was because the
okay
if I strip everything back I can't speak
for Marvin Keith when I say this as well
for me podcasting I just saw it as
there's so much talent out there and we
don't get to see them because we focus
on what it is they're producing so like
when I say what they're producing so
like an actor we only watch their movies
a musician we only watch listen to them
listen to music sorry yeah a footballer
we only watch them play football but
there's so much more to them yeah so I
felt like podcasting was that space
where they can actually come and sit me
down and be themselves yeah so that's
what was kind of like that's why a lot
of the early guests even though they
might have been big in their fields a
lot of them were our bridgens okay yeah
because I'm introducing to my listeners
I know a wavy dude listen to him that's
why moggs for example is one of our
favorite people refer to him as the
fourth shot okay because he's
essentially marg's mashtown
gone clap CE blah blah blah he's that
guy I'm scared of him oh my God but when
you sit down with him but you'll love
this guy but people started seeing that
more when he was doing filthy and doing
all of that stuff and then the Pod and
now he's got his own pod you kind of see
that right this beer man has got
personalities so then imagine if some
random dude just come down and sit down
so that's kind of why I wanted to start
podcasting just to kind of share my
stories and then let other people share
their stories wow because we're not all
just one-dimensional yes
to all of us yeah man gang say less that
was a that was a really good origin
story my bro it was paying it was
actually better than it was yeah a lot
better there's nothing there that makes
me a villain though is there oh
now I'm playing who do you support can
you talk about Champions League football
team yeah
oh yeah I think we've had this year
[Music]
bro but what kind of it happens man why
Liverpool though bro my dad supported
him I'm assuming my dad supported him
because of John Barnes
you know like a black man Arsenal fan
started with it you're right yeah to be
fair you're right you're right with the
Liverpool I could have been an awesome
fan you know okay say less but anyway
we're gonna wrap up the show with a
little game right right
everyone knows the game it's called
finish the lyrics
say here's how the rules go rem's going
to give us rem's going to give us uh
obviously your old school r b Connor sir
this should be hella light for you
hopefully
um so REM is going to give us a 10
second timer after I say the first bar
you've got 10 seconds to either complete
the ball or complete however many lyrics
you want to complete you get one point
for a correct bar and you get three
points for the bar as well as giving me
the artist and the song name okay cool
yeah considering you are the first
person to play this game the pressure is
on because yeah
you need to set the president yeah
because you can't have next man come in
here and just double double your score
you know what I mean so the pressure's
on all right cool yeah
so we're just going to do a little test
STAR to see where your where your brain
where your level's at yeah all right
cool I'm outside in the AMG what field
what failed field you don't know the
looks of this one
so badly what song is this I'm outside
in the AMG right outside TT two-time
baby girl you know me to be fast not old
school RnB I know that's not a Bible
Drake bro what song
I didn't like that tape I'd ask if you
liked it brother that's fine let's find
this fight Jesus all right yeah yeah
yeah I know it I know where this is
going but you get the context all right
let's go first you go first I'll go
first all right excuse the voice a bit
croaky all right Barry White
you ready yeah yeah you got the timer
already yeah cool
you ready ready all right this [__] was
a lot new you and me only hey I did it
all for you and still you can't
um hey we come back it up what else hey
[__] Chase
what was the song yeah tell me
I just need you to say okay uh Drake
Timberland say something guy wow
thank God for that yeah you go I'm up
yeah yeah all right cool
um all right she made us drinks to
drinks
[Music]
um
I don't know the lyrics but um
all right
when I'm with somebody all I think about
is you
so you say that again I don't even know
what you're saying when I'm with
somebody all I think about is you
know should I give you the second yeah
I'm gonna deduct the point that's fine
when I'm on a loan that's all I want to
do
no I miss the smiley faces a massage
chick other time did this all the time
together no makes it hard to get you out
of my system you don't know what you do
to me you don't even understand damn
I know you know the song about the song
I don't know the lyrics yeah yeah
everyone knows the song brother I'm not
gonna I'm not gonna lie the first one I
was like wow wow
it's the first one I was like you said
me all right cool
all right let's go for
um uh I'm actually you know what I
actually had one I was gonna go Chicago
freestyle but this guy doesn't know the
[__] demo tapes so I'm just gonna
allow him on that one I'm gonna go for
another one for redeem yourself all
right
I ain't never had nobody show me you're
the things that you're gone
when you hold me we could always be
together baby that's what you told me
you're not really because I never had
nobody
come on
Bow Wow
um is it Omarion no nah nah female
Sierra yes what's up come on
like you okay thanks all right say let's
nine points that's nine points nine out
of 12. all right cool are you ready yeah
vato you won't believe what I saw
I don't know the name of this song
taser what's a vato you won't believe
what I saw I saw these pack of guys and
they act real hard
first of all I'm I'm gonna vouch for
Tays in this one you're not doing old
school old school r b in the slightest
how is battle in the old school
regardless it's an old school track bro
it's an old school track he promised him
r b I promise you all schools I said
you're an old school head
trust me you'll see the crowd all right
cool you see the crowd react all right
cool
um
scrub is a guy that thinks he's flying
also known as a bus stop always think
about what he got and he still
so no I don't want your number no I
don't want to CLC No Scrubs say less
come on I provide everything you need
and I got some questions and I gotta ask
him
[Music]
21 Questions let's go feature it
featuring come on you're singing the
person that's singing right now
you think 57 is singing that
who's singing that
the hook
wait the part that you just said that is
50 cent no snake dog bro
Bob I've never seen 21 questions
um written featuring Nate Dogg bro
you're just talking about Nate Dogg last
week in your podcast as well
wow all right what have I got uh easy
one it's five in the morning
wow I know it's five in the morning
you know what's five in the morning
after the lyrics that's the name of the
song no no no
[Music]
all right I've got one more how many you
got I've got one more as well all right
so let's go on I was checking this guy
next door when the parents but now chief
on said
hey boy
sorry I'm sorry
[Laughter]
[Music]
this is
the song what's the type of saying bro
can you feel
thank you
hey that's jokes listen nah Craig David
sorry about Craig Davis will be insane
less you got two points you can get any
lyric
it was in my head you know I'm so mad
about Craig David yeah I know his songs
I don't know the lyrics the only song
that I know the lyrics to for some weird
reason is um the one where he goes to
the barbershop
it's like you've got a place I listen to
it passively but like actually intent
nah do Santana a little wins it's dead
say less Drake minus dark dark Lane demo
tapes you need to listen to that tape
right I walk up one more
um or easy every time I try to leave
so I'll keep calling me back
pulling me back
there you go let's go featuring
if you're bad it's not even if you're
better hey I know I know but he didn't
yeah yeah true so it is if you're bad
come on brother you think chingy's
singing that he's not singing no I'm not
but back in the day RB they didn't do
the features this one is definitely the
feature bro he's in the video more than
chingy's in the video
sing the chorus to yourself but are you
singing it because it's not shinky it's
not ching you sing it deep down close
your eyes who's singing picture the
video
well it's my mind's gone blank Tyrese
bro yes yes
aggressive with it
say less how many points you get
we're giving it we'll give him one for
that we'll give him one for that yeah
yeah 17 total 17. hold on
one because I didn't say Tyrese yeah but
you didn't get any lyric
yeah
eighteen out of how many was it 24
questions 10 is uh
thank you for coming on thank you for
having me man yeah man just what's your
social shout out your social it's going
to be everywhere it's going to be
popping up here it's going to be in the
description below but taser black on
Instagram taser black on Tick Tock and
yeah just check out the r b and slow jam
experience featuring Chucky myself and
Chucky uh slow Dash jams.com
yeah man all the descriptions all the
links and everything will be
descriptions below all the handles and
everything will be descriptions
displaying right now so yeah man thank
you for coming on and as always guys
love love
[Music]
thank you